eeuu y las sanciones que ha impuesto a
irán ya nicolás maduró podría ser uno de
los temas fuertes de esta asamblea dado
el escenario que representa donde los
países pues prácticamente tienen la
oportunidad de tener un cara a cara
entre sus gobernantes representantes o
delegados
yo soy muy buenas noches santiago así es
además es que en medio mundo está
pendiente de sí cara cara virtual entre
ambos mandatarios después de que como
decías eeuu hayan puesto esas sanciones
a irán ya venezuela por violar el
embargo de armas impuesto a teherán de
momento este anuncio va a suponer un
momento de tensión de problema para
algunos países incluso para aliados
europeos como alemania como francia y
además también como reino unido que ya
han dejado claro que estas sanciones
pues carecen de efecto legal porque al
final eeuu que salió del acuerdo nuclear
en el 2018 y precisamente el secretario
general de las naciones unidas
antonio guterres se ha dicho que la onu
tampoco se decantará se decidirá hasta
que el consejo de seguridad no se decida
desde luego vamos a ver un
enfrentamiento en esta asamblea general
como decías un escenario mundial único
en el que ambos mandatarios podrán
defender sus posiciones y para eso no
vamos a tener que esperar mucho porque
mañana mismo es el turno de ambos por
tradición donald trump intervendrá justo
después del discurso de él
de brasileño yer bolsonaro y más hacia
la tarde será el turno del presidente
iraní hassan roban y mamen justo hoy
compensaron estas rondas de
presentaciones a lo largo del día en
esta asamblea general de las naciones
unidas cuáles son los detalles de esta
jornada que estuvo básicamente enfocada
en el multilateralismo
sí pues esta jornada de santiago se ha
dedicado a celebrar el 75 aniversario de
las naciones unidas y se ha que se ha
podido conseguir una firma por parte de
los estados miembros de una declaración
de que se va a luchar por fortalecer el
multilateralismo justo en un momento en
el que el mundo se encuentra más
polarizado que nunca por la pandemia en
la que nos encontramos ha sido muy
interesante escuchar las intervenciones
del presidente de venezuela nicolás
maduro quien ha apuntado a que este es
un momento para defender la labor de la
organización mundial de la salud y no
para atacarla justo precisamente cuando
el presidente en eeuu donald trump
continúa con esos ataques directos a la
gestión que ha hecho de la pandemia este
organismo además también ha pedido al
secretario general de las naciones
unidas a antónio guterres que envía una
comisión técnica para vigilar las
próximas elecciones que tendrán lugar el
día 6 de diciembre interesante también
el discurso del presidente chileno
sebastián piñera quien ha asegurado que
es el momento de modernizar este
organismo la organización
y las naciones unidas y ha dicho también
que es el momento de reformar el consejo
de seguridad de las naciones unidas
porque se ha quedado un poquito anclado
en el tiempo y porque ya no responde a
las necesidades y desafíos de los
tiempos actuales